there's a 10 billion dollar bitcoin bet
on stable coins that's about to play out
pay attention because this is going to
be a big big deal now algorithmic stable
coins these have been a fascination of
people across technology finance and
academia for a long time the idea is
that you can actually keep stable value
in a crypto token without having to back
it with dollars or any other type of
asset you can simply peg the token to
one dollar of value but there's all
kinds of complexity and challenges that
come with it you have algorithms and you
have all sorts of technology that's
trying to arbitrage the value to a
dollar but no one has figured out how to
do this sustainably in up and down
markets and so ultimately tara which is
creating a public blockchain that has
decentralized stable coins on it they're
realizing that their algorithmic
stablecoin might not best be suited for
the future now what they are going to
attempt to do is transition their
algorithmic stablecoin ust to a
bitcoin-backed stablecoin that's right
algorithmic stablecoin now to a
bitcoin-backed stablecoin here's how
they're gonna do it ust is their
decentralized stablecoin that is pegged
to one dollar and of course there's
another token called luna in the tarot
ecosystem that luna token is used to
actually arbitrage or absorb the
volatility that brings the individual
stable coin back to one dollar it's also
used for staking and mining in the
ecosystem now here's exactly what's
going to occur the luna foundation has 3
billion dollars in their reserves that's
across bitcoin tether and luna they are
slowly converting that three billion
dollars into bitcoin that's partially
how they're going to start to back ust
with bitcoin but also when they issue
brand new ust historically what they've
done is they've actually burned one
dollar of luna for every one dollar of
ust that is created in the future they
may only burn sixty percent of that one
dollar of luna the other forty percent
of the one dollar will go to buy bitcoin
an example of this would be if i want
ten dollars of usd rather than burning
ten dollars of luna now what i'm likely
to do is i'm gonna burn six dollars of
luna and four dollars of luna will be
used to buy bitcoin ultimately the goal
from the terra team is to take 10
billion dollars and buy bitcoin become a
persistent buyer in the market if the
team successfully does this they will
show the playbook for central banks and
stable coins on how to back other assets
with bitcoin bitcoin is decentralized
hard money it is the most pristine
collateral in the world if tara
successfully backs their stablecoin with
bitcoin this will be the standard every
asset in the world is ultimately going
to need collateral and if bitcoin is the
pristine collateral if it's the superior
form of value ultimately every single
asset that is being created in the
digital world they're going to back it
with bitcoin bitcoin is the future and
what we're watching here is tara a 15
plus billion dollar stable coin issuer
somebody who has the fourth largest
stable coin in the world they're
realizing their algorithmic approach may
not be ideal it's simply better and
easier to just back their stablecoin
with 10 billion dollars worth of bitcoin
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time